previously on TV sins superman's a
no-show you've got no powers no offense
this guy might be working for the enemy
we don't know
two minutes of opening credits that
include cars oh one this guy knows
exactly where this story is heading
won't be long until the final books hit
the shelves and we can see where this
brilliant story goes read and watch all
together at the same time Game of
Thrones curse of the Black Pearl
puking before a fight puking because of
motion sickness these things are
understandable puking into an
overflowing bucket of stomach bile and
apricot chunks because nobody wants to
take their ass up top to aim that over
the side that's messed up this show has
a lot of dark in it this may be the
darkest young kings London hasn't been
home for 20 years
and the season feels like it's taken
about 20 years for Stannis and his crew
to get to King's Landing this is the
ninth episode of the season consisting
of ten episodes and the entire season
has been 37% Stannis on a ship he's got
ships he's a big deal get it let's get
to some King's Landing killing already
look at those pristine teeth in a world
with no dentists or data like now man
lord of the pearly whites people of
King's Landing did not choose the false
King Joffrey Baratheon
your better point is that they don't
like him not that they didn't choose him
they don't do democracy here they do
dictatorship or war or farcical aquatic
ceremonies Stannis will burn every
Lannister he can find if you're so
worried about burning alive maybe go
ahead and move those candles away from
the highly flammable curtains blowing
into your bedchamber oh you and
everything I have so far now this is the
spin-off HBO has been waiting for che
solving all of life's problems in her
own unique way a single drop in a cup of
wine suffices to soothe ragged nerves
three drops will bring on a deep and
dreamless sleep 10 drops however side
effects may include dizziness shortness
of breath and dragon loins product may
be harmful the women who are expecting
demon smoked babies please consult a
maester if your megalomania lasts for
more than four hours product not
intended for child murder but hey you do
you word around the writers desk is that
there was a nasty fight between two
opposing views on what men do before war
ultimately a healthy meal and a good
long rest lost out to brown ale sweet
harmonies and bare titties because you
know HBO don't feel sorry for him yeah
up your ass before the nice through
those jabs you think you're hot man
because the show doesn't have enough
antagonism among characters let's go
ahead and randomly introduce some
tension between sander and Braun not
like there's a war to go fight or
anything also I'm sorry
Braun and hound or having a serious
discussion about killing people but all
I can do is watch this naked woman on
Braun's lap and there's never a close-up
of Braun without having her in the shot
too it's like having a bunch of
fireworks go off
in the middle of a big scene quieter and
more fun but accomplishes the same
destruction I'm not entirely sure of
what you're suggesting I'm entirely sure
you're entirely sure what I'm suggesting
have we taken ass it off for Peter
Dinklage yet he absolutely owns this
show man what killer performance will
hissing off and a sinister always pays
his debts then Matt you asked for the
plan is to get to the gates as soon as
they open we sent half the party for
avatar fly to the passage fast passes
and the other half to Expedition Everest
meet back at rainforest cafe they don't
have to tease but they do have anaconda
pasta and it's delicious
I don't believe I've ever told you how I
was cut ah yes the story of the UNIX
system I know this also if I had made a
list of Game of Thrones explanations I
could go my whole life without hearing
how Lord Varys is chopped off would be
at the very top of the list for a man in
service to such powers to sit on the
Iron Throne I can think of nothing worse
wait I'll stick around beerus because
I'm guessing dark magic on the throne
won't even make the first 100 things of
awful things the show has in store I've
never known bells to mean surrender they
want to play music with us let's play I
haven't heard this budget on a bell
since that episode of the Father Dowling
mysteries where none was found dead with
bells stuck up her ass and regardless of
whether or not that episode actually
exists the amount of Google searches I
just inspired brings me great joy it's
this marilyn manson's the beautiful
people stay safe my lady and you my lion
I love the tenderness in this
relationship and I'm excited to see it
continue to blossom for seasons to come
can't wait for that to happen where's
our fleet coming because hearing
characters talk about war are so much
more fun for viewers than actually
watching war
Lancel tell the Hound to tell the king
that the hand is extremely busy whoa
whoa whoa there game of Thrones
you've got some 1980s sitcom in my early
21st century fantasy epic bad fausto
bloomin medieval Playtex commercials
also my landscaper asked my wife this
question recently and now I'm wondering
if that was incredibly inappropriate and
why he needed to know where the rest of
I get the Geoffrey's an idiot and he and
terian don't exactly get along but the
idea that he would be in on none of the
discussions involving battle plans or
that Tyrion wouldn't clue him in is
ridiculous it creates fun tension in the
show but they could have had Joffrey be
the wiser and still made this just as
tense and exciting there's no one on
board right so how exactly did they
manage to get this boat to this exact
place at the exact right time we already
heard that the wind was blowing into
Shore and if you're relying on the tide
let's just say accuracy isn't in your
favor I'm just saying this plan goes to
hell nine times out of ten when that
boat doesn't cooperate Wow yeah oh sure
now that we know the big wildfire secret
the entire ocean looks like it's
radioactive but just a second ago before
the big reveal
there was not a speck of green behind it
at all wildfire more like wild liar am i
right dad the guy we are supposed to
empathize with is the only guy who sees
an obvious danger about to happen
even though obvious danger should have
been obviously dangerous to everyone
cliche in the same way Tyrion is showing
he is a force to be reckoned with
despite his size this is also the exact
moment that Game of Thrones stood up and
said TV budgets we'd be making mother
movies up in here so deal family they
take this city but maybe put on a helmet
first sheesh worse than a prometheus
crew member and then the director said
let's have him clumsily juggle three
apples while avoiding the battle so it
looked like even more of an [ __ ]
the gods have no mercy that's why their
gods that's theists tears aren't a
woman's only weapon the best ones
between your legs holy Sh I didn't know
that people in these olden times had
access to the movie teeth if the city
Falls these fine women should be in for
a bit of a rape pep talks look at those
men in heavy armor flying across the
water against the tide
I'm impressed to my untrained eye I
thought they were slapping their oars on
the surface like a baby in the bath I
would have thought if you wanted to come
this fast you would have to stroke a lot
harder um phrasing oh come on
knock loose clearly this was a moment to
say fire the arrows are literally on
fire there's so much cutting in this
action scene I was starting to think I
had accidentally switched over to the
Thor the dark world for a second and who
gets put on stone-throwing duty I didn't
realize anything could get lower in the
ranks than a royal fluffer but stone
thrower might indeed accomplish that I
will be gone meanwhile on seriously in
the rest list and I was sold to some
stranger like a horse to be ridden
whenever he desired you will Roberts
Queen and you will be Joffrey's enjoy I
mean that's terrible what a great line
Kings presence is good for morale all
the whining sniveling morale you can
handle and more the editing on Game of
Thrones is usually pretty Baskerville
but multiple cuts just to show a ladder
getting put up
that's CW level they're as good as some
of the action is in Blackwater I don't
think this episode has once established
where everything is these are a bunch of
Stannis's boats going to some piers and
Kings Landing but where exactly are they
in relation to well everything else and
maybe the series itself is established
the locations over time but
not sure even the biggest nerd of Game
of Thrones Maps could tell you where all
this is happening these fire festival
documentaries just keep getting weirder
and weirder stairs my uncle and
represent the King on the field and
fathom Joffrey this varus doll is way
too lifelike I wonder if it's
anatomically incorrect
why does Tyrion take this guy out before
calling for the rest to attack when you
have the element of surprise why give it
away early I'm just saying the strategy
doesn't have a leg to stand on it won't
give him a leg up could it cost them an
arm it up you know what let's just send
this move on
Tyrion strikes that blow and then blood
comes a second later from the top right
of the screen I'm pretty sure whoever is
listed in the credits says off-screen
blood tosser just lost their job Tywin
ex machina gentleman which brings me to
my next point don't smoke crack no faith
in my captain
[Music]
oh wait I will pray for your safe return
middle just as I pray for the Kings out
sterile population you a slice of cake
just waiting to be play by play till
we're finished should we sing a hymn Oh
miss behind though
[Music]